well you have to build machines that
know that they don't know what the
objective is and act accordingly to the
extent that the machine does know the
objective it can take actions as long as
those actions don't mess with parts of
the world that the algorithm isn't sure
about you'd need the machine to actually
ask permission and it would have an
incentive to do that so it knows that it
doesn't know what the objective is but
it knows that its mission is to further
human objectives
stuart russell welcome to the show
thank you nice to be here
what do king midas and artificial
intelligence have in common
good question um
so king midas is famous
uh in two ways right so he he had the
golden touch so people
uh think of him as kind of a lodestone
for getting rich
um but the moral of the story with king
midas is he said i want everything i
touched to turn to gold
and he got exactly what he wanted
so the gods granted his wish and then he
finds out that he can't eat because his
food turns to gold he can't drink
because his wine turns to gold and then
his family turns to gold
so he dies in misery and starvation and
this tale is basically
a description of what happens or what
might happen
with super intelligent ai where the
super intelligent ai plays the role of
the gods
uh and we are king midas
and we tell the ai this is what we want
and we make a mistake
right
and then the ai is pursuing this
objective um
and uh and it turns out to be the wrong
one
and then we have created a conflict we
basically created a chess match between
us and the machines where the machines
are pursuing pursuing some objective
that
turns out to be in conflict with what we
really want
and that's basically the story of how
things
go south with
super intelligent ai
and if you look at what alan turing said
in 1951 he was on the radio
bbc radio 3
the third program
and um
and he said
basically uh we should have to expect
the machines to take control
end of story
uh and i think this is what he had in
mind that that they would be pursuing
objectives and we would have no way
to stop them or interfere with them
because they are more capable than us so
they control the world
that's the challenge the fact that it's
not just the objective is misaligned but
it's that the power deploying that
misalignment is so vast that there's no
stopping it once it's set away
yeah and um
you know if you're if you're a gorilla
or a chimpanzee or whatever you know you
thought
you know your ancestors thought that you
know they were the pinnacle of evolution
and then
they accidentally made humans
and then they lost control they have no
uh no control over their own future at
all because we're here and we're smarter
than they are and end of subject
yeah it's rare that the person that's
supposed to be or the agent that's
supposed to be in charge is actually
less capable or less powerful or less
intelligent
than the agent that they're commanding
to do their bidding
yes um yeah we don't have any good
models for how this relationship would
work
um so even if we do solve the control
problem
um
there are various
issues that we'll still have to face
um
so for example
how do we
retain
anything resembling the kind of
intellectual vigor of civilization
when our own mental efforts are just
puny compared to to those of the
machines that you know we're supposed to
control so
you know and in some science fiction
books um for example ian banks is
culture novels which i highly recommend
to your listeners
um he struggles with this because you
know they've got
super powerful ai and everything is
hunky-dory
um
the ai systems always do
stuff that's beneficial for humans but
in in a way they end up treating humans
like children
and uh there's always sort of this
delicate balance which parents have
right
um
when do i stop doing up my kids
shoelaces
and make them
do their own shoelaces
right and
and it's except that
with parents and children the children
are not supposed to be the ones who are
in control of the parents sometimes they
are but they're not supposed to be
um
and
you know so we just don't have a model
for that where the children are
commanding the parents but the parents
are treating the children like children
and saying okay well i think it's time
for johnny to
you know learn to do his own shoelaces
so i'm going to hold off on helping
johnny today
um
you know i just i just don't exactly
know how it's going to work
and how
humans are going to continue to have the
incentive
to slog through 20 years of education
and so on
to to learn things that the machines can
already do much better
that's thankfully not a problem that we
need to deal with just yet i suppose the
fact that we don't have an imminent well
i suppose we don't know if it's going to
be a hard take off so it might be
imminent it might be tomorrow
but everything suggests that it's not
have you got any conception around how
long it will be
before we do face a super intelligent
agi
uh
well usually i say i i will not answer
that question
[Laughter]
and i was at uh
i was at a a world economic forum
meeting which was officially off the
record
under chatham house rules and i was
somebody asked me that question
so i said well you know off the record
uh there's a number what is i did
i said i said off the record you know
within the lifetime of my children
um okay and you know that's a flexible
number because medical advances might
make their lives very long
um
and then
20 minutes later it's on the daily
telegraph
front page when was this
uh probably 20
15 i think
uh january 2015.
um
professor predicts sociopathic robots
will take over the world within a
generation okay that was what the head i
said so
so i am
you know even though i tried to be
cautious i still got screwed so i think
um
so i'm actually more conservative i i
don't think
it's going to happen
very soon i don't believe that
just
scaling up the methods we have is going
to create super intelligence
you know simply put you make the
machines faster you get the wrong answer
more quickly
what's the bottleneck that we're facing
at the moment then is it hardware is it
algorithms
uh it's definitely not hardware i think
we probably have more than enough
hardware to create super intelligent ai
already
i think it's
well algorithms but it's
basic conceptual gaps in how we're
approaching the
problem um
you know our
our current deep learning systems
in a real sense don't know anything
um
and
so uh it's very hard for them to
accumulate
knowledge over time what does that mean
that they don't know anything
so
they can
learn they can learn a sort of an input
output function
um
and
in the process of doing that they can
acquire internal representations that
facilitate
uh the representation of that function
and so on
but
um
you know they don't
they don't learn
let's say newton's laws of physics
uh
and then become able to apply those laws
to other problems right they have to
sort of retrain from scratch or almost
from scratch
on new problems and if you think about
the way science works right which is the
best example of
human accumulation of knowledge
right
we know that it wasn't
uh
simply the accumulation of raw
sensory data
and then training a giant network on on
vast quantities of raw sensory data
because all the people who had that
sensory data are dead
right so whatever they learned whatever
they accumulated
uh
had to be expressed in the form of
knowledge
right which
subsequent generations could then take
on board and use to do the next phase
and so a cumulative learning approach
based on
the acquisition of
knowledge which can be used for multiple
purposes
we don't really know how to do that at
least in the deep learning framework
in the
classical ai framework where we had
explicit representations of knowledge
using logic or probability theory
that could be done and i still think it
can be done
in those paradigms i just think we need
to put a lot more effort and maybe to be
a bit more flexible i think one thing
we've learned from
from deep learning is that
there is advantage
in being
as it was sloppy
um
so that we
we don't have to think okay how can i
learn newton's laws well i'm going to
put
f and m and a together in some order and
i'll eventually find the right law right
that assumes that you have f and m and a
already as precise precisely defined
concepts but in the learning process
you can be more sloppy right you don't
have to
have exactly
the precise definition of mass and
exactly the precise definition of force
you can have a kind of a sloppy
definition well it's
you know something there's something
going on about how
big and heavy the thingy is right and
there's something going on about how
hard am i pushing it and there's
something going on about how you know
how is it moving
and gradually those things gel
and so you can simultaneously learn the
knowledge and the concepts that that go
into the formulation of the knowledge
and so
i think that
that idea is
something that we could bring back to
the classical tradition
um
and improve it
what are some of the challenges around
language
uh so this is a second big area where i
think
we need breakthroughs
so the language models that we have
right now gpt3 and so on
which everyone is very excited about
uh
their
their job is basically to predict the
next word and they become very very good
at predicting
the next word and and um
and then they can
uh having predicted the next word they
can then add that next word and that's
how they generate
text right so you can just keep
repeatedly applying it and it will start
spitting out things that look like
sentences
and so on um
but
what they're really doing is is
predicting the next word based on all
the previous words that were in the text
sequence
right
and
it's a little bit like
astronomy
in the time of ptolemy
so ptolemaic astronomy
was what happened before we had any idea
that
the planets were
massive objects moving under the force
of gravity
so we plotted out the apparent motion of
of the planets and through the heavens
and we
basically described their shape and if
you look at the shape if you sort of
plot it out over the course of a night
it's this
you know mostly sort of some somewhat
circular looking arcs but with wiggles
and
spirals and and so on added in or you
know over long time scales because of
the relative motion of the planets
around the sun
and
um so tolic may have catastrophe just
consisted of describing those big
complicated
wiggly circularly spirally shapes
and
and then you could
gradually extrapolate them right so once
you understood the pattern of this big
wiggly spirally shape you could you
could then
extend it
you know okay i got the shape now i'm
just gonna you know keep drawing it you
know and say okay well next week the
planet should be here and you'd be right
and so that's sort of what's going on
with
these these text prediction algorithms
right that they're they're taking all
the previous words which is by analogy
to the positions of the planets and then
saying okay i get the shape i'm going to
predict what it's going to be uh in two
words three words forwards into the
future
but there's no sense of why
right why is the word on the page the
word is not on the page because the
previous thousand words were on the page
right that's not the
real cause
of why that word is there the real cause
of why that word is there is because
um
there's a world
outside this in the text
and someone is trying to say something
about it
right
um
and that's sort of the what i call the
physics of text
right there's no knowing beyond the
simple output so this is i guess is this
similar to a philosophical zombie in a
way that you're able to output a thing
that looks like it's a simulacrum of
intelligence within a sort of narrow
band
but there's nothing going on deeper
below the surface
uh that that's one way i'm i'm not i'm
not here talking about
yeah is there real conscious
understanding we haven't got that yet
but just
does the
does this
causal model
of
why the text is there do you does that
approximate
reality in any way no
right the reality of text is that people
are trying to say things
and they're trying to say things about a
world that they live in
and are acting in
so
you know the simplest model would be
they're just trying to say true things
but
actually they're trying to get something
done in that world and and part of
getting something done is saying true
things and sometimes it's saying false
things and sometimes it's asking
questions
um but this
you know you can see this connection
you know why the real world matters
because statistically
the fact that there's a real world and
we're all talking about the same real
world means that every document in the
world is correlated with every other
statistically so if one document
says
jk rowling wrote harry potter
right
and another document you know written in
russian
you know a year later says
you know the author of harry potter is
you know what do you expect the next
word to be well
you expect it to be jk rowling because
they're talking about the world
and
um even if this is a new way of saying
it in a new language
uh it's correlated through the this
common hidden variable if you like which
is the real world and none of that is
um
is there in current deep learning models
of language
so i think they're fundamentally
flawed
um and this is one of the reasons why
they take
trillions of words of text i mean they
read
about as much as all human beings in
history have read
right uh
you know and so
and they're still you know they still
make stupid mistakes
they still kind of lose the plot right
one of the things you see is that
because they have a well you know
they're predicting the next word based
on a relatively
limited memory
of the previous text they kind of lose
the plot
so as they go on they'll start either
repeating themselves or
uh contradicting them what they said
earlier on in in the text and so on um
so you know having said that
they do exhibit quite impressive kind of
short-term
recall and question answering
um
and uh
and a certain amount of generalization
is going on right because you can you
can see that because you can
you can ask them questions or you can
tell them things using
uh a name or a place that they've never
ever seen before and then you can ask
them questions about that name or that
place uh and they'll answer it correctly
so there's there's some generalization
going on right they've learned a general
pattern and then they're able to
instantiate the general pattern with
particular people or places or whatever
it might be and so um
you know that that's a sign that
learning has happened
but generally we don't understand what's
going on
beyond that and so we don't know when
they're just spouting gibberish
right you think it's answering your
question and actually it's just about
incomplete gibberish
you don't know
i suppose the challenge here is that the
main way that we communicate is through
language so
if you're not a computer programmer and
you wanted to have a conversation with a
super intelligent agi home assistant you
would need to tell it
what you mean it would not only need to
be able to understand the words that
came out of your mouth but our language
our use of language is imprecise also so
it also needs to be able to work out
what you meant to mean not just what you
said then it needs to interpret it then
it needs to be able to convert that into
something that it can do within itself
and then it needs to enact that so yeah
i mean
yeah so i mean we we built systems that
could do that
even in the 60s and 70s um
you know and they sort of work
the way
you would expect they they understood
the structure of the language they
what's called parsing the sentences so
figuring out what's the subject what's
the verb what's the object
and then converting that into an
internal logical representation
and then
doing the reasoning necessary to answer
the question or to add the fact to the
system's internal knowledge base
uh and then generating
answers to questions and converting the
answers back into language
you know so that
that process
you know we've
we've known how to do it's just been
very difficult to make it robust
because the variety of ways of saying
things is enormous
um you know we speak in ways that aren't
grammatical but still perfectly
comprehensible
um
you know we do things like lie right the
last thing you want to do is is for the
system to believe everything everyone
says because
uh then then it's very easy to
manipulate so it has to understand that
what we're
you know what's coming out of our mouths
is as as wickenstein put it as a move in
a game
right it's not gospel truth it's an
action that we're taking
and the action might be to try to fool
you or to try to make you do something
that you wouldn't otherwise do or
whatever
so that you know that level is
completely not there right you can
gpt three takes all text as
gospel truth or whatever right it
doesn't distinguish between
fiction and and fact between propaganda
and truth and so on it just it's all
just text
what are some of the big ways that we
could get artificial intelligence wrong
so i think the
um
the current approach to ai which has
been there really since the beginning
and in the book human compatible i call
it the standard model uh which is a word
that people use in physics to refer to
you know all laws of physics that we
pretty much agree or write
um
so an ai the standard model has been
to build machines
that
uh that behave rationally and and this
notion of rational
comes from philosophy and economics that
you you take actions
that you
can be expected to achieve your
objectives
okay and that you know that goes back to
aristotle and
other places
um
so we took that model
and we created ai systems that fit that
model now with people we have our own
objectives so we can be rational with
respect to our objectives of course
machine doesn't have objectives
intrinsically
so we put the objective in and it seems
like a perfectly reasonable plan right i
i get in my automated taxi i say take me
to the airport right that becomes the
taxis objective and then it
takes me to the airport it figures out a
plan to do it and and does it right
um and uh
pretty much all ai systems have been
built on this basis that
um
uh one of the inputs that's required to
the algorithm is the objective
you know if it's uh a game-playing
program
you know the objective is checkmate or
whatever that whatever it might be if
it's a
a route planning algorithm then it's the
destination if it's a reinforcement
learning algorithm then it's the reward
and punishment definition
um
and so on so and this is
this is a pretty common paradigm not
just ai but
uh you know the control theory systems
that fly are
airplanes
right they they minimize a cost function
so the engineer specifies a cost
function which
penalizes deviations from the desired
trajectory you know and and then the
algorithms you know will optimize a
given cost function
um
and
uh
okay so what's the problem with that the
problem is as i mentioned earlier when
you brought up king midas
we don't know how to specify the
objective completely incorrectly
and so for artificially defined problems
like chess it kind of chess comes with a
definition of checkmate so it's
you know it's sort of fooling us into
thinking that this is an easy problem to
specify the objective
but take the you know the automated taxi
the self-driving car
all right is the destination the
objective
well better not be because
you know then it might drive you there
at 200 miles an hour and you know you
you come home with 50 speeding tickets
and
uh if you weren't dead you know so
obviously safety is also part of the
objective right okay well
fine safety but then how do you trade
off
safety and getting to the destination
right
um
if you
prioritize safety above everything else
then you're never going to leave the
garage because just going out onto the
road incurs some risk
right well okay so now we have to put in
some trade-off between safety and making
progress
and then you've got you know obeying the
laws then you've got not pissing off all
the other drivers on the road uh you
know then you've got not shaking up the
passenger right by starting and stopping
too much and uh and it goes the list
goes on and on and on and the
self-driving car companies
are now facing this problem and they
have
whole committees you know and they have
meetings all the time trying to figure
out okay we would
get the you know the latest data from
our cars in the field and all the
mistakes they made and you know tweak
all the objectives to get them to behave
better
and so on so even for that problem it's
really hard and if you had something
like
you know curing cancer or
uh you know fixing the carbon dioxide
levels right you can see how things go
wrong right you want to cure cancer
really fast
it sounds good
okay great well then we'll we'll
induce tumors in the entire human
population
um so that we can run millions of
experiments in parallel on different
ways of curing them
you just don't
you don't want to be
in that situation
right
and so
the the answer it seems to me
is
we have to get rid of the standard model
right and so here my you know i wrote a
textbook
based on the standard model in fact it's
sort of in many ways it it
it made the standard model the standard
model and
you know
and here am i saying actually sorry
chaps um we got it all wrong
and we're going to have to they're going
to have to rebuild the whole field um
and uh you know so you've got to get rid
of this assumption
that the human is going to supply
the complete
fixed objective
it's too
complex or it'd be too arduous i'm going
to guess to be able to program in
plugging the little holes in the bottom
of the boat for each one of the ways
that the machine could slightly go off
course so you've got safety okay we
write the safety algorithm okay we've
got speed we write the speed algorithm
i'm going to guess that the goal would
be to get a more
robust
sort of scalable
general solution to this
that would be able to find a problem a
solution to all potential problems that
would be able to optimize the outcome
across all potential challenges
yeah sort of i mean it's
if you if so i mean basically what you
have to build machines that know that
they don't know what the objective is
and act accordingly
so what does act accordingly mean
uh well
to the extent that the machine
does know the objective
it can take actions as long as those
actions don't mess with parts of the
world
that the algorithm isn't sure about your
preferences
right you know so if
if you if you have a machine that's
going to try to
restore carbon dioxide levels in the
atmosphere to
their
pre-industrial concentrations right so
that's a really good objective
right well
you know it wouldn't be a good objective
if the solution was
you know get rid of half the oxygen
right because then we would also have
you know slowly asphyxiate
um so that would be really bad don't do
that
um okay what if it means turning the
oceans into sulfuric acid
yep okay no don't do that
all right um so you you'd need the
machine to actually ask permission
right and that's it and it would have an
incentive to do that so
it knows that it doesn't know what the
objective is but it knows that
its mission is to
further human objectives whatever they
are
so it has an incentive to ask
to ask permission
to defer if we say stop you know that
isn't what i meant
right it has an incentive to obey
because it wants to avoid doing
whatever it is that violates our
objectives
um and so you get
these new kinds of behaviors a system
that believes
that it has the objective
right becomes a kind of religious
fanatic
right it
pays no attention when we say you know
stop you're destroying the world i'm
sorry
i've got the objective you know whatever
you're saying is wrong because i got the
objective and i'm pursuing it right uh
we don't
you know we don't want machines like
that so
in this this new model it it seems much
more difficult and in a way it is much
more difficult to
to satisfy an objective that you don't
know
right but it produces these behaviors
you know asking questions asking
permission deferring
you know in in in the extreme case
allowing yourself to be switched off
right if
if the machine
might do something really catastrophic
then we would want to switch it off
now
a machine that believes that it has the
correct objective is going to prevent
you from switching it off because
that would be failing right it wouldn't
achieve its objective if it gets
switched off the machine that knows that
it doesn't know what the objective is
actually wants you to switch it off
right because it doesn't want to do
anything
sufficiently bad
that you'd want to switch it off
so it wants it has a positive incentive
to allow itself to be switched off and
so this new model
um i don't think it's perfect but it's
it's a huge step
beyond the way we've been thinking about
ai for the last 70 years
and i think it's the key
you know this the core of a solution
uh that will allow us
you know not to end up liking midas
what's not perfect about it
um
i think the
the biggest problem that i'm wrestling
with right now
is the fact that
human objectives
are actually
should we say plastic or malleable
right um and you can tell that because
you know we don't have them when we're
born right when we're born we have
pretty simple objectives
um
and uh
you know so it's something about our
culture
maturation
etc that
creates adults who have
to some extent fairly definite
preferences about
about the future so the way i think
about it is not asking you to write them
down
right because i think that that's really
that's really hopeless
um
but if you if i could show you
sort of two movies
of the future
right future a future b
um
and you could sort of watch those and
then reset yourself and watch the other
one and reset yourself
and then say which one which one do i
prefer right i think that's a
a reasonable back of the envelope
description of of what we're talking
about right the you know everything you
care about in the future if the movie
if you couldn't quite tell whether you
liked aov because there's some detail
missing then you can get some more
detail on those parts and
um
you know a a future where
the oceans are turned into sulfuric acid
and we all die
oxygen
deprivation uh it's pretty clear that's
not the future we prefer
um so
uh
the the issue with
plasticity and malleability is
that
um
although i might say i like future a
today
right
tomorrow i'm a new person
and i might like future b instead but
it's kind of too late because now you've
stuck me into future a
um
and so the first problem there is
well who do you believe right do you
you know you're making a decision now
should i respect the preferences of the
person now
or should i anticipate
how you're going to change in future and
respect your future self
and and i don't you know philosophers
haven't really given us a good answer to
that question so that's that's one part
right sort of deep philosophical issue
um
the
more problematic part is
that if our preferences can be
changed then the machine
could satisfy our preferences by
changing them
rather than by satisfying them
so we could it could find out ways to
change our preferences so that we'd be
happy with whatever it was gonna do
right rather than it figuring out how to
make us happy with the preferences that
we have
um
you know and you could say well yeah
politicians do that
and advertisers do that right
but we don't think of that as a good
thing
and it could be you know with with
machines it could be a much more extreme
version of that and so
um
so i think of what's in the book it's
kind of version zero of the theory and
version one would have to deal with this
uh with this aspect
um
you know there are there are other
difficult questions to answer
like
you know obviously machines are making
decisions not on behalf of one person
but on behalf of everybody
um and how exactly do you trade off the
preferences
of
individuals you know who all have
different futures that they prefer
and that's not a new question
um
you know it's thousands of years old
and uh you know i i think that that's
i feel that's a manageable question um
you know and cruelly speaking the answer
is you you add them up
all right um
and that's the what's called the
utilitarian approach and
we associate names like bentham and mill
um
with that idea
uh and more recently hassani who's
was a berkeley economics professor
who
won the nobel prize and put a lot of
utilitarianism onto a
uh an axiomatic footing
um
you know so he
so what it's interesting actually to to
understand what that
means because a lot of people have a you
know sort of emotional dislike of
utilitarianism partly because the word
utilitarian you know that sort of refers
to sort of you know gray plastic
furniture and you know and
count council fights branding yeah yeah
it's a branding problem exactly uh it
got sort of mixed up with um
with the with the wrong word and um
you know people complain about it you
know not being sufficiently
uh egalitarian
and
not
you know people
assume that it refers to money like you
know maximizing the amount of money in
the wealth in them nothing to do with
that
um but the kinds of axioms that hassani
proposed
um when you actually think about them
they
they probably you know most people would
accept them as quite reasonable so for
example
um
you say suppose you've got you know two
futures
you know future a and future b and
future b is exactly the same as future a
except one person is happier in future b
than they were in future a
everyone else is exactly as happy as
they were before
um
he said well it seems reasonable that
you'd say future b is better than future
a
right
and
uh so he has a couple of axioms like
that
and from those axioms you can derive
the utilitarian solution which is
basically adam up right
find whichever policy maximizes the sum
total of human happiness
um
and uh
you know so i i think there are
there are various difficulties involved
right so when you say the sum total with
human happiness are you including all
the people who haven't yet been born
and if so
what about actions that affect who gets
born
right
you know and that that sounds like you
know
that sounds pretty weird but actually
you know if the chinese government with
their one child policy right they wiped
out 500 million people
with that policy
right so they
quote killed
more people than anyone in history has
ever killed you know way worse than the
holocaust way worse than
stalin and
you know by preventing them from being
able to have existed sense of preventing
them from being existing it was huge
right
was it the right you know was that a
moral decision was that the correct
decision really hard to say
right i mean the reason they did it was
because they
were afraid that they would have mass
starvation if they had
too much population growth you know and
they had experienced what mass
starvation was like so
um you know
some it's arguable that it was a
reasonable thing to do but
it did lead to a lot of people not
existing
presumably going through
right it's really hard presumably going
for just raw utilitarianism has a ton of
awful externalities as well though
like the most happiness for the most
people okay well there's two variables
we can play about with there we could
just make tons and tons and tons of
people
you go okay well there we go we got
everyone's not that happy but there's a
lot of people and it's actually managed
to make up for it
or yeah yeah i mean this yeah this is uh
so derek poffett who's a british
philosopher um has a book called reasons
and persons and
and this is one of the arguments uh in
the book and he calls it the repugnant
conclusion
which is that we should make basically
infinitely many people who have
you know a barely
acceptable existence
um
and and if you if if you watch the um
uh avengers
you know where
one of the marvel right the one
where thanos is collecting the
the stones of power or whatever they
call and
um
he's
proposing one side of that philosophical
argument which is that you should get
rid of half the people in the universe
and then the rest will be more than
twice as happy
yeah dangerous dangerous using thanos is
the basis for your philosophical
justifications isn't it
yeah so you have to
um
you have to get these things right
and before you give him the big glove
before you give him the big glove and
and that's that's the same question we
face with ai but it's not as if there's
a you know it's not as if there's a
an obviously better
solution right so so
the alternative to utilitarianism
uh is sometimes called the deontological
or the rights-based approach where you
simply write down a bunch of rules
saying can't do this can't do this can't
do this kind of right uh have to do that
have to do that um
and
the
utilitarian can
can quite easily accommodate a lot of
those
rules right so if you say you know you
can't kill people well
children's everyone said well of course
you can't kill people because
you know the person who gets killed
that's not what they want the future to
be like
and so
so the utilitarian solution would avoid
uh murder
and
and mill goes on for
pages and pages and pages
about well of course
moral rules are
you know i'm not throwing out moral
rules i'm just saying that
if you actually go back to first
principles they follow from
utilitarianism
but we don't
have the time and energy to go back to
first principles all the time so we
write down a bunch of moral rules and i
think there are there are more
complicated arguments about
uh
avoiding strategic
complications when you when we're making
decisions in society it's much easier if
there are moral rules rather than
thinking all the time okay well if i do
this and then they might do that and i
might do this and they might do that and
i might do this right so
sort of playing this complicated chess
game with with eight billion people all
the time um it's just easier if there
are rules that everyone knows exists and
will be respected um
but
the interesting place is is what happens
um
you know in the in the corner cases
right do
do we say
no the rule no matter what the
utilitarian calculation
is the rule is absolute
and
i think the answer is
no you can start out with some easy
rules right this you know the rule says
you can't eat uh you have to eat fish on
friday
right
well you know
is that an absolute role
well i don't know i mean
if there were no fish
and my child is starving and that
you know the only only thing for them to
eat is some some meat i'll give them
some meat
right
um so
we clearly see that
you know rules are an approximation and
when when we're in
difficult corner cases we fall back to
first principles
right and and so i don't see that
there's
there's the degree of conflict
um between utilitarian and deontological
approaches that that some people see and
what you know
one of the
typical arguments
you know
might in utilitarianism might against
utilitarianism sorry would would say
something like well you know
with your organs i could save five
people's lives
right you know your kidneys your lungs
maybe your heart
so i'm entitled to just go around
ripping the organs out of people to uh
to save other people's lives
well of course that's not what
utilitarianism would suggest because if
that were
how we behaved life would be intolerable
for everybody on earth right we'd be
constantly
looking around over our shoulders and
grabbing our kidneys and things you know
so
it's just um
you know so the
the utilitarian
solution sometimes called the rule
utilitarianism is that it's useful to
have these
rules about behavior not just to
consider the individual act
but to consider what if that act were
allowed
right what if there were a rule that you
could always do that act then it would
be terrible so
so i think you can reconcile a lot of
these
a lot of these debates
but the the examples that we've
that we've already touched on you know
the
the fact that our preference changes the
fact that
we have to consider people who don't yet
exist
or might not exist
um
you know the these are important
unsolved questions no matter what
philosophical
uh place you come from it might sound
like very far future predictions but
the
user
being manipulated to make their
preferences easier by the machine is
actually something that's already
happened can you
take us through what social media
content algorithms have done
uh sure yeah so
the social media content algorithms
right they decide
what you read and what you watch
and
they do that for literally billions of
people
for hours every day
right
so in that sense they have more
control
over human
cognitive input
than any dictator in history
has ever had more than stalin more than
kim il-sung
um more than hitler
right
they have massive
uh power over human beings
and they're completely unregulated
and people are
reasonably concerned about
what effect they're having
um
and so what they do
um is basically they they set an
objective because they're
good standard model machine learning
algorithms and so they're set second
objective let's say maximize
click through right the the probability
that you're going to click on the next
thing so imagine it's like this is
youtube
uh you know you watch your video and lo
and behold another video pops up
right and am i going to watch the next
video that it sends me to watch or am i
going to you know close the window
um
and
so click through or you know engagement
or various other metrics these are the
things that the algorithm is trying to
optimize
and
i suspect originally
the the companies thought
well this is good because it's good for
us if they click on things we make money
and it's good for people because the
algorithm will learn to send people
stuff they're interested in if they
click on it it's because they wanted to
click on it yeah right and there's no
point sending them stuff that they don't
like they're just cluttering up their
input so to speak um
but
you know i think the algorithms had
other ideas
and uh
the way
um
that an algorithm maximizes
click-through in the long run is not
just by learning what you want
right because
you are not a fixed thing
and so
though you can get more
long-run
click-throughs if
you change the person
into someone who's more predictable
right who's
uh for example you know addicted to a
certain kind of violent pornography
right and
so youtube can make you into that person
by
you know
gradually sending you you know the
gateway drugs and then
more and more
extreme content whatever direction so
the algorithm doesn't know that you're a
human being or you have a brain
right as far as it's concerned you're
just a string of clicks
right content click content click
content clip right and um
but it wants to turn you into a string
of clicks
that in the long run there's more clicks
and less
uh less non-clicks
and so it learns to change people
into
more extreme more more predictable
mainly but it turns out probably more
extreme
versions of themselves so if you know if
you
indicate that you're interested in
climate science it might
try to turn you into an eco-terrorist
you know and
you sell you know articles full of
outrage and
um
and so on if if you're interested in in
cars it might try to
turn you into uh someone who just
watches endless
uh and endless reruns of top gear why is
the person that's extreme or predictable
well i this i think this is a this is
that's an empirical hypothesis on on my
part right that
if you're more extreme you you have a
higher
emotional response
to content that affirms your
uh your current views of the world and
so what in politics we call it red meat
right the
um
the kind of content that gets the base
riled up about you know whatever it is
that i love about whether it's the
environment or or you know immigrants
flooding our shores or whatever it might
be right you know if once you
once you get the sense that someone
might be a little bit upset about
too many immigrants then you you send
them stuff about all the bad things that
immigrants do and you know you know
videos of people climbing over walls and
uh sneaking into beaches and
all the rest of the stuff you know and
it's
human propagandists have known this
forever
but
historically human propagandists could
only produce one message
whereas the content algorithms can
produce
in theory one propaganda stream for each
human being
specially tailored to them
and
the algorithm knows how you engage with
every single piece of content right your
typical
you know hitler's propagandist sitting
in berlin had absolutely no idea
on a moment-to-moment basis how people
were reacting
to the stuff that they were broadcasting
right they could see it in the aggregate
over longer periods of time
that certain
certain kinds of content was effective
in the aggregate but they don't have
anything like the degree of control
that uh that these algorithms have
and
you know the
one of the strange things is that we
actually have very little insight
into what the algorithms are actually
doing so what i've described to you
seems to be a
logical consequence of how the
algorithms operate and what they're
trying to maximize
um but i don't have hard empirical
evidence that this is really what's
happening to people um because the the
platforms are pretty opaque
but they're even they're opaque to
themselves
they're a picture themselves so you know
facebook's over his own oversight board
doesn't have access
to the algorithms and the data
to see what's going on who does
i think
the engineers
but their job is to maximize click
through
right
uh
so
pretty much there isn't anyone
who
doesn't already have a vested interest
in this who has access to what's
happening and and that i think is
something that we're trying to fix
um
both at the government level
so there's uh there's this new
organization called um the global
partnership on ai
which is
um
you know it could just be you know yet
another do-goody talking shop but it
actually has government representatives
sitting on it so
it can make
direct policy recommendations to
governments
and it ha in some sense it has the
force of governments behind it when it's
talking to
the facebooks and googles of the world
so we're in the process
of
seeing if we can develop agreements
between governments and platforms
uh for a certain type of transparency so
it doesn't mean
you know looking at whatever you know
looking at what chris is is watching on
youtube you do not want to do that you
do not want to do that
it means
um
you know being able to find out you know
how much terrorist content
uh
is is being pumped out where is it
coming from who is it going to
uh slightly more sort of aggregated
stuff like typical data scientists do
yeah so and and
possibly being able to do some kinds of
experiments
like you know if
if the recommendation algorithm works
this way
you know what effects do we see on users
compared to an algorithm that works in a
different way so to me that's the
the really interesting question
um
is
you know how do the
recommendation algorithms work and what
effect do they have on people
and if we find that they really are
manipulating people
right that they're they're sort of a
consistent drift
um that a person who starts in a
particular place
will get driven in some direction that
they might not have wanted to be driven
in
then that's really a problem that we
have to think about different algorithms
and so in in ai we often distinguish
between
reinforcement learning algorithms
which
are trying to maximize a long-term sum
of rewards so
so in this case the long-term rate of
clicks
on the content stream is what the
algorithm is trying to maximize those
kinds of algorithms by definition
will
manipulate
because the
the action that they can take is to
choose a particular piece of content to
send you
and then the state of the world that
they are trying to change is your brain
and so they will learn to do it right a
supervised learning algorithm
is one
that's trying to
get it right
right now
right so they are trying to
um
predict whether or not you're going to
click on a given piece of content
right so a supervised learning algorithm
that learns a good model of what you
will and won't click on
could be used
to decide what to send you in a way
that's not based on reinforcement
learning and long-term maximization but
simply
okay given a model of what you're likely
to click on we'll send you something
that's consistent with that model
right
in that case
i think you could you could imagine that
it would work in such a way that it
wouldn't move you it wouldn't cause you
to change your preferences but
um
if it was done right could sort of leave
you roughly where you are
um are you familiar with the term
audience capture you know what this
means from a creator an online creator's
perspective
i
i can imagine but not as not as a
technical term yeah well it's not it's
not a technical term but it's basically
when you have a particular creator
online who finds a message
narrative rhetoric that resonates with
the audience and what you see is that
this particular creator becomes captured
and they start to feed
their own audience a message that they
know is going to be increasingly more
well liked and for the most part this
actually does look like a slide toward
one side of the
one particular direction or the other at
least politically it does but with
anything it does too that people
inevitably sort of niche down and then
they bring their audience along with it
so the fascinating thing here i mean
first off it's
unbelievable that these algorithms that
are simply there to try and maximize
time on site or click-throughs or watch
time or whatever
that they have managed to find a way
things that we programmed managed to
find a way to program us for it to be
able to do its job better i mean that
when i read that in your book i
it's insane like that's one of the most
terrifying things that and it's
happening right it happened like
everybody that's listening to this has
had something occur with regards to
their preferences their worldview
whatever it might be something has slid
in one way or another you may be right
it may not be toward the extremes
i would say anecdotally based on what i
see in the world increasing sort of um
levels of partisanship no matter what it
is whether it be sports politics
race relations
anything
people are moving toward the extremes
why is this happening oh well you know
it's people getting into echo chambers
and they're only being shown stuff like
that
and also the fact
that the algorithms are actually trying
to make them more predictable but on top
of that as well there's another layer
which is the creation of the content
itself that comes in from the creators
and they
have
their own levels of manipulation which
is occurred from their feed then they
kind of second order that into what do i
want to create what have i seen that's
successful what does my audience seem to
resonate with from me
so you have layers and layers of
manipulation going on here yeah yeah and
i think i you know in some ways the
creators are are being manipulated by
the system
um you know i think every journalist now
is thinking
okay
i have to get something that's clickbait
i have to
write an article that can have a
headline that is sufficiently attractive
that it'll get clicked on you know and
it's almost the point where the you know
the headline and the article are
completely divorced from each other um
and and you can see this now in the
comments right the the people writing
the comments at the end of the article
will say oh i'm really i'm really pissed
off this is just click bait you know the
article really doesn't say anything
about the thing you said you were going
to say
so on so
so this
it was not as if this has never been
going on and obviously you can't
you can't ban people from writing
interesting articles or you know i often
think about you know the novel and it
says on the back i couldn't put it down
right what should we ban
novels here because that's addictive you
know you can't have that right uh
no but i think
it wasn't too bad before
because
the
feedback loop was very slow
and
there wasn't this you know
targeting of individuals by algorithms
who are you know so you think about the
the number of learning opportunities for
the algorithm
right i mean it's billions every day for
the youtube
uh selection algorithm right so it's
the
the amount
the consistency
the frequency and the customization of
the learning opportunities for
manipulation
so much greater i mean it's you know
millions or billions of times greater
and more systematic
and that that systematic element so it
reminds me there's this i don't know if
it's apocryphal but there's a
um there's a story about the psychology
lecturer and he's been teaching the
students
about subliminal
uh effects
and the you know the students decide to
play a trick on him
which is you know every
every time he's on the left-hand side of
the room
they pay attention they're really
interested
and every time he walks onto the
right-hand side of the room they all
really bored you know start checking out
the email and so on and uh by the end of
the lecture he's glued against the left
hand
right and he has no idea that he's being
manipulated
um but because of the fact that this was
like systematic
and uh you know and sufficiently
frequent it has a very very strong
effect
uh you know and i think that
that's the difference here is that it's
because it's algorithmic
and it's tied into this very high
frequency interaction
that people have with social media it
has a huge effect
and it has i think a pretty rapid effect
as well
what are some of the concerns you had
you mentioned earlier on about is it
enfeebled becoming too enfeebled to the
machines
uh yeah so this is i think one of one of
two major concerns
you know if we manage to create
superhuman ai and to control it
um
one concern is
um
the misuse concern right so i call it
the dr evil problem right dr evil
uh doesn't want to use the provably safe
controllable ai he wants to make his own
ai that's going to take over the world
and you can imagine
that gets out of control and then bad
things happen
um
the enfeeblement problem is sort of
overuse right that we
um because
we have available to us ai systems that
can run our civilization for us
um
we lose the incentive
to know how to run it ourselves
and
um
that
problem you know it
it's really it's
it's a really hard problem
to figure out how to prevent it
because inevitably the ai would have to
make the human do something that
probably in the moment the human didn't
want to do the ai would actually be
programming itself to be
less useful
than it could be in order to give us a
sort of homesis stressor dose that
allows us to stay useful
yeah i mean it's um
so when i say overuse i mean i i
literally mean that right that we would
use ai too much for our own good
um
and uh so e.m foster has a story
you know so he usually wrote
you know late victorian early edwardian
social
you know british upper class social
issue kinds of
novels but um he wrote a science fiction
story called the machine stops
which i also recommend to your audience
um and
um
it's it's quite amazing right it uh
it has the internet
email
um
1909
it has uh ipads video conferencing um
you know people are obese because they
never get out of their chairs they're
stuck on the computer all the time
they start to eschew face-to-face
contact
because they are um
basically
glued to the screen
and uh
and lose contact with the physical
environment altogether you know all the
kinds of things that people can
complain about now
uh he wrote about um and and the machine
right so it's not just the internet it's
the whole it's a whole
it's called the machine
that looks after everyone's physical
needs
and so
um
so they just spend their time
glued to the screen they don't know how
the machine works anymore
and uh
they don't need to because the machine
runs itself and then of course
it stops running itself and
things go south um
but
you know i i did a little back of the
envelope calculation so it turns out
that that about a hundred billion humans
have lived
and
um
our civilization
right is passed on by teaching
the next generation of humans everything
we know and then maybe they'll learn a
bit more
right and if that process
fails
right
you know if it goes into reverse that
the next generation knows less
right then things you could imagine
things unraveling
and um
you know so the total amount of
spent just
passing on civilization is about a
trillion
person years of effort
and
for that to end would be the biggest
tragedy uh
that one could possibly imagine
right
but if we have no incentive
to learn it all because
finally right instead of having to put
it into the heads of the next generation
of humans we can just put it into the
heads of the machine and then they take
care of it
right
um
and if you've seen wall-e
right that's exactly what happens right
and they they even show what happens to
the generations over time right they
become
stupider and fatter
and
unless you know they they can't run
their own civilization anymore
um so the machines should say because
this is such an important thing right
it's of value to us and to our
descendants that we are capable that we
are knowledgeable we know how to do
things
um that we have autonomy
and intellectual vigor
those are really important values but
so the machines should say
okay we're going to stand back and let
these humans they have we have to let
the humans
tie their own shoelaces
right other ways they'll never learn
but we
right we are short-sighted lazy
greedy people and we might say no you
have to tie our shoelaces
keep doing that
and then
we when we lose that autonomy in that
intellectual vigor
so this is a cultural
problem right it's a problem with us the
technology might be saying no no no no
but we're overriding it
all of these problems all of these
problems are problems with us
the problems are the fact that our goals
are plastic the fact that our language
is imprecise the fact that we are
sometimes rational sometimes irrational
that we don't have a an omnipotent view
that we can see what we want when we're
going to want it also these challenges
around the fact that sometimes we want
something in the moment that we're not
going to want in the future and that
we're going to complain at the algorithm
and say well no no machine you're
supposed to be here to do my bidding and
now you're telling me that i've got to
walk to the shop to get the milk i want
you to get the milk well sire i don't
know why he's middle-aged middle-aged
he's peasant now well say you must go to
the get the milk yourself you know that
it is good for your calves and your bone
density so
like i mean this we haven't even touched
on how this even begins to be converted
into computer code which is
i imagine
a whole other complete minefield of
difficulty to be able to actually get
what we're talking about this is purely
sort of within the realm of philosophy
what are the what are some of the
challenges that we have here when you
have a
all-powerful super being that can do
whatever you want
yeah i mean it's inevitable
in a sense because
what we what we've always wanted is
technology that's beneficial to us
and
a lot of the time we say oh well here's
a here's a technological idea
you know i hope it's going to be
beneficial to us like you know the motor
car
for example right
um
and then turns out not to be
or at least arguably although it
conveyed lots of benefits it might have
ended up being our
destruction it's one of the black
boston's black balls right or grey balls
i suppose out of the urn
it's uh yeah so it it
it's responsible largely for uh
for the destruction of the climate
and so
unless we unless we get out of this it
will have been a really bad idea to do
it
but almost by definition with something
as powerful as
as ai
or a super intelligent ai
you need to know it's either going to be
very beneficial or very not beneficial
right it's not going to be like
margarine versus butter or something
like that right
and so
so we have to ask ourselves
okay what does beneficial
mean
right if we're going to prove a theorem
that such and such you know developing
such attack such technology is actually
going to be beneficial
um
then inevitably it comes back to
what are humans and what do we want
uh and how do we work
and so
um
yeah so that that kind of surprised me
when i started along this path
of
trying to solve the control problem
um
you know i i had
ideas for algorithms that
uh that would do it and so on but i
didn't realize the extent to which it
would
push me into these
uh these humanistic questions
um and that's been fascinating and it's
it's a little bit of a minefield for
you know for a technologist to stray
into these areas because they
they're they operate in different ways
in many ways they're much more vicious
than
the uh
the technological feels because you know
in technology it's sort of it's
there's us humans and then you know it
works or it doesn't right or it's true
you know it's a true scientific theory
or isn't
um
so there's this
third party called nature
out there um
but in the humanistic areas there isn't
a third party right it's just
you know one school afford another
school debates all the way down fighting
it out for supremacy
um and it
takes a while to adjust to that
um but the questions are
you know super important and
and really fascinating
uh so i've enjoyed it
a lot um so coming back to the
the question of
the algorithms
right
um
you know one way to think about it is is
that that's
perhaps a little bit less daunting um is
to
to look back at
what's happened in a.i
with respect to
should we say ordinary uncertainty
so in the early days of ai
we mostly worked on problems where
the rules were
known and fixed and deterministic like
the rules of chess
or
you know finding a path through a map or
something like that right
we know what the map is we know that if
you turn left you go left so
um so we can have logical rules we could
use
these deterministic symbolic techniques
to solve the problem and then we found
that as we moved into real world
um
uncertainty becomes really important
right so
uh you know if you're controlling the
mars rover
uh and you have to you know you give it
some command to you know to go
70 meters in a particular direction
because it takes 10 minutes for the
commands to go backwards and forwards um
is it going to get there well you don't
know it might get stuck or it might you
know deviate a little bit or you know
one wheel will will start spinning and
it won't make any progress or who knows
so
real world problems
you always have to handle the
uncertainty in your knowledge
of um
the physics of the world and in your
even just
what your senses are telling you right
that their
senses themselves are imperfect and
noisy and incomplete
so uncertainty became a core
consideration in in ai around 19
early 1980s i would say
and so that period from
you know late 80s to
early 2000s was really the period where
probability
was
you know the dominant paradigm for ai
research
but in all that time
it does not seem to have occurred to
anyone except for a few
you know
i think very bright people
that there is also uncertainty in the
objective
so we have all these problem
formulations for decision making under
uncertainty but they assume that you
know the objective exactly and perfectly
um
and at least looking back at that now is
like well that's bonkers right it's just
as bonkers as assuming you know the
physics of the world exactly and
perfectly or that your senses give you
exact and perfect access to the state of
the world at all times right um
because you know we had already seen
many examples of
objective failure right where we
specified the wrong objective and the
machine did something complete you know
that we thought was completely bonkers
because in fact it was doing exactly
what we told it to do we just didn't
realize what we had told it
and my favorite example
is um
one from uh
from simulated evolution
and um
you know so simulated evolution you you
you define a fitness landscape
right so
which simulated creatures are considered
to be more fit or less fit and therefore
they get to reproduce and
mutate and gradually you can evolve
creatures that are really really good at
whatever it is you want to be good at
so um
so the objective was
uh well what they wanted was
to evolve creatures that could run
really fast
so they specified the objective
as
the maximum
velocity of the center of mass of the
creature
and um that sounds like a perfectly
reasonable definition so so what evolved
enormously tall trees like a hundred
miles high
that would then fall over
and uh and in fall like they went really
really fast so they won the competition
right they they
they turned out to be the solution to
that problem someone thought they were
going to get some supercharged nitro
cheaters or leopards or something
exactly instead you end up with trees
reaching up into the stratosphere and
then falling all over the place
yeah
uh
so you know i thought that was a great
example you know and of course that's
only you know that's a simulation in the
lab so people for ho ho ho and i mean
okay let me fix the problem because in
the real world right in in your climate
engineering system or your
you know your economic governor or
whatever it might be right there
you can't just go ho ho ho and use it
we'll fix it now it will press the reset
button brian christian told me about a
problem robots playing football
and they'd
put a very small utility function in
for gaining control of the ball
the possession is an instrumental goal
towards scoring that you can't score if
you don't have the ball
and what the robot found was that it
could actually maximize its utility
function by going up to the ball and
vibrating its paddle 100 times a second
up against the ball which is far easier
than actually trying to score yeah it
ended up
thinking it had done really great and
the guys just had these sort of
seizuring robots all over the pitch
vibrating up against the ball
yeah exactly right um
which is sort of what happens with
little little kids sometimes right they
want to get the wall and they want to
get the wall they like they don't know
what to do with it once they've got it
yeah
but anyway the yeah i mean that
some of these problems have technical
solutions that
that particular one
there's a there's a theorem for what
kind of supplemental rewards you
you can provide
that are intended to be helpful
um
but will end up not changing the final
behavior so it'll make it easier to
learn the final behavior but it will
ensure that the final behavior is still
optimal according to the original
objective so you could you can fix that
aspect of the problem but you know if
you leave something out from the
objective you left it out
and
that's equivalent to saying it's worth
zero
right so
anything you leave out of the objective
is like saying it has it it's a value
zero to humans and that's
you know that's a big problem
so you you almost always want to say
well i told you some of the things i
care about but there's other stuff i
haven't told you and you should be aware
of that
it feels to me like there's sort of two
cars in this race on one side we have
technological development that has lots
of facets hardware
algorithms so on and so forth and then
on the other side you have the control
problem you have getting the alignment
right
it has to be
that the alignment problem gets across
the finish line
before the technology does
or else we are rolling essentially
rolling the dice and hoping that we've
got it right by some sort of fluke and i
imagine that there are far more ways of
getting it wrong than there are of
getting it right
[Music]
yeah well i mean
getting it wrong
is actually the default right if we just
continue
pushing on the ai technology in the
standard model we'll get it wrong are
you so is there any chance that if you
continued with the standard model that
it could be right or would you give it
such a low chance that it's negligible
i think it's negligible or you know
arguably
what's happening with social media is an
example
of getting it wrong
um you know and i the other people have
pointed out that you know we don't need
to wait for ai
corporations that are maximizing
you know quarterly discounted profit
stream
are also
examples of machines pursuing
incorrectly defined objectives that are
destroying the world
and you know
you could if you look at the climate
issue from that point of view i find it
sort of enlightening right we we have
been outwitted
by this
ai system called the fossil fuel
industry
right it happens to have human
components but
the way corporations are designed right
they are they are machines with human
components
and
um actually the individual preferences
of the humans
in those machines don't really matter
very much
um because the machine is designed to
maximize profit
and uh and they outwitted the human race
they
developed you know for more than 50
years they've been running
global propaganda and
uh subversion campaign
to keep you know to enable them to keep
um
selling
uh fossil fuels
and they won
right we can all say we're right or we
know
we know that we shouldn't be doing this
and we know that
we know the causes of climate change and
right but we lost
a lot
fewer implications
of that
than an all-knowing all-powerful
artificial intelligence though so
although the implications are still
grave if the climate problems get worse
it's not the same
and again this the control problem
simply has to get across the line if
you're essentially adamant that
currently if you scale up the
competence
not probably not com the power i suppose
of the computation that we have um
it's bad it's bad it's it's a bad
situation
yeah but obviously you have
is the irreversibility right i mean
climate change probably isn't going to
make us extinct
you know unless unless there's some real
chaos theory
catastrophe happens
and eventually we'll all be so fed up
that we actually retake control from the
fossil fuel industry and that's sort of
happening
um
but yeah with ai
it could be irreversible
there's lots of control
uh and
you know if
if i'm right
that
examples like social media are showing
that we are already seeing the negative
consequences of
incorrectly defined objectives and and
you know even relatively weak
machine learning algorithms that are
that are pursuing them
um
then we should pay attention right these
are the canaries in the coal mine
we should be
saying okay we
[Music]
we need to
slow down and we need to
you know look at this different paradigm
and
you know the the standard model is sort
of just one corner
right it's the corner where
the objective is completely and
perfectly known at least that's the
that's the corner where it's appropriate
to use the standard model
right and this is all the rest of the
building
we haven't even looked at yet
right where there's uncertainty about
what the objective is and the system
can
uh behave accordingly
um and we've just you know just in the
last
few years have we had any algorithm that
can
solve
uh this new
category of problem and it does i mean
so the algorithms exist right they're
they're very simple and they work in
very
uh
restricted and simple
instances of the problem but they
they show the right
properties
right that they
they defer
they ask permission
um
they
understand what the human is trying to
teach them about about human preferences
and um
you know it see it seems
our job in what's
called for whatever better word the ai
safety community
our job is to build out that technology
to create all the new
algorithms and theoretical frameworks
and and
demonstration systems and so on to
convince
the rest of the ai community that this
is the right way to do ai
because we can't
do the other thing in the race we can't
slow down the technological progress
because
trying to neuter one particular
agent or actor or country or nation
state or even one group of nations
doesn't guarantee that
some other group is not going to china's
saying right we'll stop doesn't mean
that america will say
we're just going to keep going or vice
versa
yeah well it's just i mean
the the
potential upside that people are seeing
is so
huge right i mean
when i say it would be the biggest event
in human history
i mean it
why
right it's not
because
it you know
our advantage as humans our whole
civilization is
based on a certain level of intelligence
that we have right so we our brains are
the source of the
the intelligence fuel that
that makes our civilization go around if
we have access
to
a lot more all of a sudden right that's
a that is a step change
in our civilization
um
and uh
you know on the upside it
might enable us to solve
problems
that have been very resistant like
disease
poverty conflict
and
on the downside it might just be
the last thing we
do so
if you could if you had a god's eye view
would you
put a pause on technological development
for
a hundred years outside of the control
problem for a thousand years for
50 000 years because
we've spoken about the
dangers of
killing people that haven't yet been
born and when you're talking about
civilizational potential the observable
universe you know galactic-sized empires
von neumann probes making everything as
a you know you're talking trillions and
trillions of human lives even if you go
from the utilitarian approach you have
an unlimited amount of utility and
happiness that could be given and
because we're unable at the moment to
slow down technology
potentially within the next hundred
years
all of that could be snuffed out
yeah it's it's interesting
in in many of the works i think in
boston's and in max tegmarks and others
the argument is based on the you know
these quintillions of future humans
who might
you know be able to colonize the
universe
and so on it that that's never been a
motivation for me
right i mean if i if i have a picture
it's just of a small village with a
church and people playing cricket on the
on the village green
um
and that's what i do here i don't want
that to disappear i don't want
the civilization that we have
to be gone because it's the only thing
that has value
and
um i
i try not to think about what would i
what would i do if i was god as you say
uh it's not
good for the ego
well it's just um
i i mean obviously i don't
no no one i think is going to be able to
switch off
um
scientific progress
you know it
there are precedents um
the biologists switched off progress
on direct
modification of the human genome
in ways that are
what they call heritable modifications
germline editing
um
they switched that off they said you
know in 1975 or gradually from 1975
onwards they
they decided that that was not
something they wanted to do
which is interesting because
a large part of the history of genetics
and
that whole branch of biology
the improvement of the human stock was
actually one of the major objectives
um
you know and eugenics before the second
world
war thought of itself as a noble
uh a noble mission
you know you could argue about about
that but um
but the biologists to say you know what
we could do this
but we're not right um
that was a big step and
you know is it possible
for that to happen in ai
i think it's much more difficult
um
because
in
biology right
we are continuing to understand
right so the uh developmental biology
right so how does
a given dna sequence produce an organism
right and what goes wrong and you know
is it a problem
uh with the genes or a problem with the
the development environment of the
organism or or what
and if you understand all those
questions then presumably you could
you could then say okay now i know how
to
modify the human genome so we can avoid
all those problems
um
so this the scientific
knowledge is
moving ahead
but the decision is we're not going to
use that knowledge for that kind of
thing
and you can draw that boundary pretty
easily because you know we're talking
about
physical
you know physical procedures involving
actual human beings and
uh and so on and that's been regulated
for many decades already and so
with ai
once you understand how to do something
it's pretty much done
right there um
mathematics and code are just two sides
of the same coin
and uh
you know
mathematical ideas you can't
go around looking at everyone's
whiteboard and saying
okay i see you've got you know
sigma for x equals one okay stop right
there right yeah that's that's one too
many greek symbols you've got to stop
writing right
you know so
we
because
the question of
you know decision making and learning
and so on these are fundamental
questions we can't stop research on them
so i have to assume
that
the
scientific understanding of how to do it
is just going to continue
to grow
if if it was the case which some people
seem to think that
to go from a scientific understanding to
a deployed system would require
you know some
massive gigawatt installation
you know with billions of gpus and so on
and so forth and then perhaps you could
regulate
at that point
because there would be a physical
limitation that would be quite easy to
enact okay you can't have this many this
much power this many i'm going to guess
that you
feel otherwise that you don't need that
much hardware to run something that
could be quite dangerous
correct yeah i
i think we already have enough power as
i said um
and
uh it
you know it's it's very hard to do
meaningful calculations but in just in
terms of raw
numerical operations per second
um
a google
tpu pod
which is the tensor processing unit you
know even
three or four years ago
was operating at a higher rate than the
possible theoretical maximum capacity of
the human brain
right so
the ballpark figure for the human brain
is 10 to 17 operations per second
but i don't think any neuroscientists
believe that
we're doing anything like that much
right i mean
they would probably ball pocket at 10 to
the
12 or 10 to 13 or something like that
but if you
if you grant every possibility it's 10
to the 17 where or you know
tpu pod which is you know sort of
wardrobe sized
thing it's a 10 to the 17 you know the
biggest super computer is a 10 to the
18.
um
so
uh you know i think we have way more
than enough power to build a super
intelligent machine
so i just don't i don't think that
trying to cut it off at the
you know large-scale hardware
installation level is going to be
feasible either anymore you know if you
remember the old
um apple ads
for the g5
so the us had these exp put export
controls on anything that was more than
one gigaflop
right which sounds ridiculous now but
they put x-book you know because they
didn't want those falling into the hands
of the russians or the chinese so
they're
you know so apple produced this ad you
know with that little g5 like this
little cube and they had all these tanks
like surrounding this little g5 and
saying you know
this this little g5 is now under you
know the us government has has too hot
to handle yeah exactly right so it's you
know they used it as advertising
material so it's um
you know it it's just unlikely that you
could
uh
that you could
prevent the creation of super
intelligent ai
just by regulating hardware
installations
so
so i do think of it as as you say a race
um
i think
you know we may
see catastrophes that are more obvious
and
um unequivocal than what's happening in
social media
um
and you know so that could happen on a
small scale and self-driving cars
you know i i thought
when the first tesla
completely failed to see a huge white
truck and crashed straight into it at
full speed
i thought
you know that kind of accident should at
least say okay maybe these ai systems
are not as good as we thought they were
um but didn't seem to have much impact
um
and you know we've we've killed several
more people pretty much the same way
so it would have to be
i think something
something pretty major
would have to happen well you say that
but i've been thinking this
over the last 16 months that kovidge
should have been the biggest wake-up
call for
symbio for natural pandemics for
engineered pandemics for research into
that any anything over that side of the
aisle for whatever is bsl 3 or bsl4 labs
they should all be on the moon they
should all be you know on the bottom of
the ocean we should be air gapped from
them
and no one's talking about that rob reed
rob reed's talking about it and that's
it like there's no one no one's bothered
they're not i think i i don't know i
i have heard some biologists talking
about
reevaluating
after this global pandemic maybe maybe
we should have a meeting you know have a
cup of tea or something but i just think
humans um because life's so comfortable
at the moment for us mostly and because
we have
attached our sense of well-being to the
progress of technology i think everybody
is praying at the altar of that
currently and the presumption is always
more technology is good there may be
some hiccups along the way but
mostly we'll be able to fix it and if we
can't we'll make a technology that can
fix it that will be enabled by the
technology that was wrong
but there is a as you say a step change
you know it's not just a change in
degree it's a change of kind when we
reach this particular level recursive
self-improvement blah blah blah game
over well i think um
arguably the same thing is going on in
biology whether it's germline
modification or
you know synthesis of
pathogens
you know and and
interestingly you know in for dna
synthesis there is a response
uh it's not
widely publicized but
um
all the manufacturers of dna synthesis
equipment
are now
building in
circuitry
which is non-public right which is a
black box
circuitry which is checking
the sequences to make sure you're not
synthesizing any disease organism
and there i think there's even a
notification requirement so if you try
someone will be knocking on your door
very quickly
um
you know so that that's a that's i think
a very sensible precaution
um
and
you know and even so right that there's
a movement within synthetic biology sort
of libertarian
movement the garage movement saying we
should be able to synthesize whatever we
want it's our right you know it's
scientific freedom
i'm sorry
i i think you're nuts
right there is there is no you know
scientific freedom is
is a value but it doesn't trump all
other values including
continued human existence
so
um
you know an
eventually i think ai you know computer
science and ai have got to accept
the same thing
right we
we've now
reached a point
where we're able to have a really
significant effect on society
for good or bad
and so
that's time time to grow up right it's
time to accept that you have
responsibilities
and that society has a right to control
what effect you have
that's a whole other conversation there
when we think about the current push
towards libertarianism on the internet
web 3.0 decentralized you can't stop me
you can't stop my money i can be
wherever i want do whatever i want with
whoever i want i think that there's
going to be a serious sort of cultural
conflict there you
one of the reasons that you wrote human
compatible was as a wake-up call to
people within the sort of ai research
safety community
we're approaching what two years almost
exactly two years since it was published
what has the effect
of the book and your subsequent
work press been has it had anything
close to the impact that you intended
has had any other sorts of impacts
um
that's a very good question and
honestly i don't know the answer um
there's certainly more academic interest
in these topics um
you know the number we have a center at
berkeley and
the number of people coming to the
workshop
has been increasing
rapidly
um
you know workshops that we hold at at
the main conferences
are growing really fast hundreds and
hundreds of people
um
i often you know i get emails from all
kinds of ai researchers
who
say you know okay i i agree with
everything you're saying in the book you
know how how can i redirect my research
to be helpful in this
um
i believe
based on various sort of grapevine
uh dribs and drabs that
the questions of uh
control
have filtered up to the highest levels
of government
in various countries
um
that this is now one of the risks that's
considered you know when people take
stock of okay what what do we need to
pay attention to
over the horizon this is one of the one
of the risks
but you know on the other hand i i
if i was just a
you know mid-level ai manager in
in a technology corporation
uh
you know would i change what i'm doing
well i think
my recommendation is
is always
look at the objective
that you're specifying
for your
algorithms
look at the actions that your algorithm
could take and ask
could any of the effects of your
algorithm
go outside
the scope that you are thinking of for
your objective
and have you thought about all the
possible consequences and whether they
would be desirable
that should be something that we do
as a matter of course and i would say
you know the
the new eu
ai regulations um actually
instantiate some of that
um
so that that's
that's reasonably good
um
so i but
there is no you know i can go and buy
tensorflow i can you know i can go
download reinforcement learning
libraries you know there's tons of
software in the standard model
um but there's almost nothing in the new
model
right so there's just tons of research
literally every chapter of the textbook
has to be rewritten from scratch
and you can't rewrite it until someone's
done all the work to create the new
algorithms and the new theorems
and even
to figure out the
the right way to formulate the problems
so
that's something that i have to do and
my students have to do and the other
groups around the world that are working
on this and the sooner we get that done
the better right these will be better ai
systems
it's not
you could think of them as well okay
you over there doing those traditional
ai systems you're bad bad bad bad bad
you know and you need to fix your fix
your approach um
that's never been very effective
as a way to get people to change their
behavior right what you want them to get
up in the morning and say i'm going to
build a really good ai system today
but what that means is one
that is beneficial to human beings
right and and just like an engineer
a civil engineer who designs bridges he
gets up every morning and says i'm going
to build the best bridge
i can right and what is best bridge
means well it's come to mean bridges
that don't fall down
all right and i was reading the um
the memoir of the guy who ran the
russian bioweapons program
and it was clear that he got up every
morning and said i'm going to do the
best science i can today
what did best mean for him it means you
know making anthrax more fatal you know
and
and uh
making making infectious diseases more
infectious right that's what best meant
for him so
you can affect
what people do by affecting what they
think of as good science or good
engineering
and it's to me it stands to reason that
it's not good engineering if it does
things that
make you very very unhappy
uh
we need to change the way people think
about what is good ai and then give them
the tools
to make it
and time's running out
yep
stuart russell ladies and gentlemen
thank you very much for joining me today
if people want to check out your stuff
where should they go
uh so the book human compatible
is available
uh including as an audio book with a
very plummy accent not mine uh so but
it's pretty good um
my web page you can google me my web
page has all the publications
um the center for human compatible ai
uh has a bunch of resources
um and then there are other groups
such as the uh future of humanity
institute at oxford uh center for the
study of existential risks at cambridge
um
future of life institute at mit in
harvard so there's there's a bunch of
groups
around the world and um we're you know
we're
working as hard as we can to train
students and
get them out into all the universities
and then teach the next generation how
to go forward
good luck to you man
thank you very much very nice talking to
you chris thank you very much for tuning
in if you enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few months and
don't forget to subscribe it makes me
very happy indeed
peace